oh the ton was a buzz at the london
premiere of bridgerton we are just two
days away from season two and can i just
say this cast looks good in any era i'm
obsessed and luckily only e.t scored an
exclusive invite oh the boys
or should we say the green carpet for
all the fashion tea
[Music]
gucci
it's lots of um lace leg out got some
sparkles
i've got little gold scissors which are
a nod to
genevieve de la croix being a dress
maker
i'll give you a little twirl it's a cake
you can hear me coming
our fave jonathan bailey used our e.t
mic as his accessory
and here's the real queen of bridgerton
miss shonda rhimes red hot and carolina
herrera but that nearly 6 000 crystal
purse shaped like a castle wasn't even
her best accessory check out her white
sneakers i like to be comfortable
something that's certainly not
comfortable those massive wigs they
actually made me a neck brace so when
things get a little bit heavy at about
four o'clock i could just put my neck in
and just yeah
kim kardashian's corseteer um
they trained all of the people that made
ours and they actually made season one
casts corsets so they're very special
corsets and they're perfectly made for
us so it many ways it does feel like
sack and skin speaking of kim she's a
bridgerton stan and so is this guy
welcome to how to tea time like a
bridgerton so could we see some cameos i
mean joe jonas is always invited can i
say i'm a bridger to now he's a
certified bridgestone now so yeah i sign
off on that yes
it would be fun to see kim on set maybe
she could come and work for madame
delacroix
this is the season the vi count intends
to find a wife
before the premiere i spoke with the
cast and got a few spoilers that even
lady whistled down would be envious of
warning season 2 doesn't have a lot of
sex instead it focuses on a love
triangle it is a delicious slow burn
with a big finish they were naked in
front of each other psychologically
before they were physically ah
come now it is not proper to stare it's
the yummiest show to look at i think yes
i agree yummy in many ways it's funny so
in the stage directions
in bridgeton it's really
expressive they're like things are
getting steamy
[Music]
you